hey it's Gordon Ramsay welcome to my  youtube channel now as you know there  are the most amazing videos that you can  actually watch from all those cooking  tips get great insights how to make that  perfect dinner as you can see behind the  scenes just about go live with mr. Ross  you almost forgot my name name  so now known as mr. we're gonna call me  Jimmy Kimmel all these American people  you're cheating on me with I would never  do that I've never done that all good  yeah I'm good we've got a youtube  channel as well I like named the show  John from our show Gordon's on it behind  the same stuff all knowed all live all  donatons check out those videos you can  have fun Riley doesn't know how to cook  you know he doesn't cook you know he's  got a cook stunt double who comes in and  he comes at the end when he's ready just  goes with that idea my mouth is  salivating beautiful on with the show  the last Jonathan Ross show ever